where do I get inspiration so I got a
great question for my newsletter readers
love you guys Leonard who wrote in to
say hey Evan where do you get
inspiration thanks Leonard short and to
the point so Leonard is a great question
and as entrepreneurs it is rough man it
is rough waking up every day and then
going to do your business when you may
not see the growth and the traction
momentum that you want and hanging in
there every day you know that's the
perseverance is part of what you need to
be successful and the inspiration that
continued that perseverance is super
critical so there are three things that
I do to stay inspired that hopefully you
can learn from number one is from famous
entrepreneurs I was always inspired by
famous entrepreneurs because when you
look at their stories you realize that
came from nothing most of the time they
came from zero and had to overcome all
sorts of adversity and obstacles and
problems and people who didn't believe
in them that the little man who didn't
believe in them and they made it and
reading those stories and now I have one
of the largest collections online on my
website of penguins entrepreneur stories
reading those inspired me and reading
them every day even if it's just a quote
or a passage or some kind of story from
them gets me excited that feels like you
know what if he can do it I can do it
too I'm not that far off I'm in the same
boat that he or she was when she first
got started and so I can do it too and
that helps keep me inspired number to
our YouTube channels I'm a visual
learner and I like seeing video and so
there are a few YouTube channels that I
subscribe to that produce regular
content and I I consume them all the
time and it gets me motivated and
inspired and gives me ideas to keep
going the three of my favorites are
where tourism who has a lot of
motivational videos Eric Thomas who has
a lot of motivational videos as well and
Gary Vaynerchuk whose vetoes aren't some
motivational but when he comes on it's
talking about social media and
strategies he's got lots of energy and
it teaches me about being a better
speaker and presenter and so I always
consume those three channels and I
and watching those videos breaks me out
of from being a you know you wake up in
the morning and you're kind of starting
from scratch every day and so watching
those videos puts me into a state or
gets me into a zone where I'm hyper
focus and inspired and ready to go take
massive action and number three is my
routine and I'm a big believer that you
need to have a routine every morning
that serves you because again you're
starting from nothing you could have had
a great day yesterday and you wake up
today and it's like where did all my
energy go you got to start off brand new
all over again and so my routine I find
really helps me so I'll wake up and i'll
have my lentils for breakfast and I'll
put on some music and it's music that
it's upbeat and exciting and uplifts me
and makes me want to feel like dancing
and it just lifts my mood and gets me
already in the zone a little bit faster
then i will look at my youtube comments
and i look at the comments and it's
always positive right you guys have
great things to say and it makes me feel
like what i'm doing is important because
now right now i'm just talking into a
camera right i mean i am this room
that's empty space by myself just
talking into a camera and it's helpful
to know that hey you know what the stuff
i'm making is touching people and it's
important work i need to keep doing it
and your comments keep that inspiration
in me going and then the third thing is
in my morning routine is I remember why
I'm doing this right and having that big
y helps keep me motivated and I'm making
these videos today and Wednesday is my
video making dates or wednesday
afternoon I'm making them today because
my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs and I want to do that
through the videos and it's the best way
I know to be able to reach and touch
people so helping me remember my big
goal my why why I'm doing this helps
keep me inspired as well so remember
learn from famous entrepreneurs YouTube
channels and your routine believe for
those of you watching like the video you
can support me by clicking on the link
in the description I love to hear we
have the thing to leave a comment let me
know what inspires you how you stay
inspired every day and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much i'll see you soon